[Musik]
willkommen bei Bild die richtigen Fragen
ja mensch das war ein Tag voller Bomben
die Eskalation geht immer noch weiter
und noch weiter und wir mittendrin
kommen wir da irgendwie noch raus und
schafft es diese Regierung uns durch
diese so dramatische Zeit
hindurchzuführen Bild stellt jetzt an
diesem Abend die Vertrauensfrage an
Wolfgang Kubicki FDP Vize an Bettina
Hagedorn die
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete an Peter Hahne
Journalist Theologe und Autor von das
Maß ist voll und an den Publizisten
Albrecht von lucain schönen guten Abend
hier im Studio und außerdem gleich ein
exklusivgespräch mit Wolfgang Schäuble
dass ich heute früh bei ihm geführt habe
und das so viel kann man schon sagen ist
wirklich in sich hat das sehen sie
gleich aber wie gesagt das war ein Tag
voller Bomben voll mit Putins Rache
glaubt ihr irgendjemand in der Runde
noch das Putins atom-drohungen nur ein
Bluff sind
also ich will das hoffen dass das so ist
sind alles andere wird alles andere
Katastrophe ich muss das hoffen wenn
eine weitere skalation würde uns eine
fast ausweglose Lage bringen wir könnten
protestieren wir können weiter
Sanktionen auslösen aber mehr wird auch
nicht geschehen ich bin doch ich bin
doch in Ruinen groß geworden und ich
weiß dass die Menschen so ab 60 65
mittlerweile ganz große furchter
Vorhaben dass der Krieg auf uns keine
Phase mehr vom hoffen deswegen frage ich
danach also Herr Hahne bereiten wir uns
tatsächlich im Kopf auf ein Atomkrieg
gerade vor also wir haben auf jeden Fall
Angst und die Frage ist ob die Angst
richtig geschürt worden ist im Sinne von
wir können durch diplomatische Mittel
müssen jetzt alles versuchen oder also
wenn ich so Kubik ist Partei genossen
die waffenlobbyistin mit dem
vierfach-namen sehe das ist für mich sie
eine Zimmermann ja das ist für mich eine
unzulässige Angstmacherei die zum
Schluss zu einer Geschäftemacher führt
wir müssen noch mehr Waffen und noch
mehr Waffen ich habe von ersten Tag
dieses Angriffskrieges der nämlich ganz
klar ein Angriffskrieg von Putin war
gesagt das löschen darf nicht teurer
sein als der Brand inzwischen erleben
wir dass das Löschen wahrscheinlich
teurer ist weil wir ein Putin jetzt
natürlich geradezu dazu drängen das
wahrzumachen was er kann er könnte auf
den Knopf drücken und ich hoffe Theologe
Christ und bete dass das nicht kommt und
das ist nicht kommt heißt wir brauchen
auch in Deutschland deswegen bin ich
sehr dankbar dass Olaf Scholz sehr
zurückhaltend ist bei dieser waffenfrage
von vornherein wir brauchen Gespräche
wir brauchen diplomatien wir müssen
jeden Faden Nutzen zu Putin Herr Söder
hat sich doch gebrüstet als erstes
Ministerpräsident als erstes zu Putin
vor der große Putin wo bleiben denn
diese Leute jetzt habe ich nicht ich
darf ich darf das hier so nicht stehen
lassen jeder jeder weiß dass ich auch in
der die Frage in etwas dezilitere
Haltung habe als Marie angeschrakt
Zimmermann aber ihre Haltung ist
nachvollziehbar sie ist konsequent und
sie wird auch von vielen Menschen
geteilt von mir nicht weil ich auch
finde wir müssen aufpassen bei
Waffenlieferung wir müssen Ukraine
helfen deshalb ist die Rück
Zurückhaltung bei Leopard 2 Panzern
angemessen
müssen wir die Ukraine mit Waffen
versorgen um sich selbst zu verteidigen
gegen einen ergressor der
völkerrechtswillig handelt und das ist
ein Unterstützung die Völkerrecht
legitim ist noch einmal geboren sie
stützen die Waffenlieferung die der
Kanzler eben auch in die Ukraine
befürwortet jetzt hören wir von Herrn
Hahne das ist teilweise Kriegstreiberei
was außerdem in der Koalition Frau
Zimmermann spricht der hane an passiert
ich habe gefragt bei den atomdrohungen
Putins ob wir tatsächlich noch glauben
dass das nur ein Bluff ist was antworten
Sie nicht was sie hoffen sondern was sie
was sie glauben womit Sie rechnen
ich rechne damit dass wir zuversichtlich
sein dürfen weil auch Putin nicht in
selbstmörderischer Absicht unterwegs ist
das würde ich immer unterstellen nein
ich finde es ist ganz wichtig dass das
ernst genommen wird von uns und unsere
Bundesregierung nimmt das auch ernst
aber ich unterstütze das was Herr hane
gesagt hat und da haben wir genau wie
auch mit wie auch Wolfgang Kubicki
durchaus ein Konflikt mit aknestreik
Zimmermann ich befürworte die
Waffenlieferung wir haben es übrigens
als Deutscher Bundestag beschlossen
selbstverständlich ganz verstanden
darf der Bundestag hat beschlossen dass
wir selbstverständlich und es ist ein
Wechsel in der Sichtweise einer
Bundesregierung wir liefern Waffen in
Krisengebieten in Kriegsgebiete das
haben wir nie getan und jetzt tun wir es
und das ist richtig damit sich die
Ukraine selbst verteidigen kann aber es
ist eben ein Unterschied welche Waffen
man liefert ob es Verteidigungswaffen
sind die liefern wir international
abgestimmt und die Leopard 2 Panzer
gehören nicht dazu jedenfalls bis nicht
weil das auf internationale Ebene so
gesehen wird ich habe es noch nicht ganz
verstanden was sie mit Putins Atom
Drohung anfangen wenn der droht und das
hat er vielfach getan und hatte andere
Drohungen immer wahr gemacht dann müssen
wir doch im Kopf damit rechnen dass er
das umsetzt dann müssen wir doch im
Moment im Kopf überlegen was machen wir
eigentlich wenn der ja ein Atomschlag
macht also glauben Sie mir ich bin ganz
fest davon überzeugt dass diese
Bundesregierung alles Szenarien
durchspielt das ist ihr verdammter Job
und das wird sie auch tun trotzdem ist
es klug wenn uns nicht einfach gelähmt
vor Angst die Beine schlottern sondern
wenn wir vernunftbegabt bleiben und das
tun wir indem wir eben nur international
abgestimmt Waffen liefern indem wir
keine Alleingänge machen und indem das
halt Olaf Scholz ja auch wieder deutlich
gemacht er hat ja mit Putin telefoniert
das wurde übrigens kritisiert ich finde
es richtig auch wenn im Moment
aber
nicht gesprächsbereit aber das ist ja
immer wieder versuchen und das finde ich
richtig und diese Bundesregierung steht
auf jeden Fall wir liebe Frau Hagedorn
können uns ja nicht wehren nachdem
CDU und CSU Verteidigungsminister die
Bundeswehr zugrunde gerichtet haben
durch lange bevor es die Ampel gab das
muss doch alles auf den Tisch das heißt
aus einer bestimmten Polizei
Sache nichts zu tun wir sind in einer
Lage und ich will an den einen Begriff
erinnern den sie finde ich in sehr
fahrlässiger Weise genannt haben
Geschäftemacherei es war keine Frage der
Geschäftemacherei am Beginn dieser
Auseinandersetzung hier hat am 24
Februar Vladimir Putin unter völliger
Missachtung des Völkerrechts ein freies
Land überfallen da ging es bei der Frage
von Waffenlieferungen nicht um die Frage
von Geschäfte macherei davon war die
Bundesregierung weit entfernt ich
spreche ist genauso aber genauso sind
Begriffe die in einer Weise Dinge
anraunen die hoch gefährlich ist es ging
damals und wir müssen mittlerweile
diesen Krieg historisieren wir so einer
völlig neuen hochgefährlichen Phase da
sind wir ja alle einer Meinung die
Atomfrage ist dramatisch aber wenn wir
ehrlich sind wenn sie mit ihrer Position
der nicht Lieferung von Waffen übrigens
auch nicht der nicht die Form von Waffen
die bereits die Amerikaner längst
getätigt habe ich nie gesagt dass ich
für die nicht dann ist ja gut dann war
das jedenfalls Erklärung bedürftig weil
der Begriff der Geschäfte macherei lässt
Dinge anklingen die in manchen Halle
des löschen ist mittlerweile teurer aber
das müsste man erklären das musste man
erklären es war so unklar dass ich es
kläre am Anfang wenn am Anfang nicht
Waffen geliefert worden wären uns ganz
klar zu sagen dann stünde heute Putin an
der polnischen Grenze das müssen wir uns
bewusst machen es war also von daher die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der Ukraine die
überhaupt verhindert hat dass dieser von
Putin erwartete gloriose Sieg völlig in
die Hose gegangen ist aber und jetzt
kommen wir zum zweiten Abschnitt wir
haben eine Wende in der Zeitenwende
die annexionspolitik durch Putin bei
gleichzeitiger Teilmobilmachung die zum
Teil und das würde ich auch kritisieren
zum Teil durchaus triumphfallistisch am
ersten Augenblick gefeiert wurde auch in
hiesigen Breiten ist ein völliger
falsche Einschätzung gewesen weil dieser
triumphialismus Putin zeigt Schwäche in
der Tat er hat sie ungemein gezeigt er
hat mich mit der teilmobil machen den
Krieg ins eigene Land getragen
mittlerweile wissen auch die Menschen in
Moskau und St Petersburg was die Stunde
geschlagen es sind nicht nur noch die
Menschen aus buchiatien und anderen
Regionen in den Krieg nein es sind alle
das heißt das Land weist einerseits
Bescheid aber die Annexion ist eine
völlig neue Situation er hat mit der
Anerkennung der Okkupation nennen wir es
so aber der Annexion dieser Gebiete hat
erklärt das ist Russland und er hat in
der Tat ohne aber was bedeutet uns jetzt
verursachen ich würde sagen wir müssen
höllisch aufpassen deswegen war dieser
auch die Aussage von Olaf Scholz das ist
ein Zeichen von Schwäche genau die große
Gefahr ein an die Wand gestellter Putin
unter
dem Drucken zu uns zumindest bewusst
machen wie ungemein gefährlich denn
Putti ist auch keine Strategie ja wir
müssen bloß wir wissen doch alle ihr
habt das würde ich sagen putin ist
mittlerweile längst getriebener seiner
eigenen Demagogie wir wissen doch dass
die kadiros die prichorgans die hinter
ihm stehen längst den belizismus den
Militarismus propagieren dem er selbst
zum Opfer fallen könnte er hat sich so
stark in diese Position begeben dass er
sagt wir verteidigen das dass daher viel
radikalere Kräfte hinter ihm sind das
heißt ich hätte eine Strategie die
ziemlich nahelig ist man kann ohne
weiteres sollte in Zukunft alles tun
zusätzliche Gebiete der Ukraine zu
verteidigen damit nicht weitere
Annexionen sie sagen aber jetzt die
zweite Sache ist falsch gefährlich wir
werden irgendwann über die Frage
diskutieren
und da wird es natürlich kommt zum
Schnur wie weit muss man die Ukraine
unterstützen also die Frage ist
natürlich dann irgendwann im Raum
beispielsweise mal ganz weit gesprochen
ich befürchte es wird davor schon
möglicherweise dramatisch werden wenn es
wie heute jetzt um die Krim geht tja
dann wird es natürlich sehr spätestens
dann passiert genau und das wissen
natürlich aber es wissen vor allem die
Amerikaner das große Glück ist das ist
zum Glück unterhalb der Ebene von Putin
längst Kanäle gibt auch der Amerikaner
die so deutlich
eine doppelte Botschaft geben Joe beiden
sagt machen sie das nicht setzen sie
hineingeschlagen
genau
und hören einfach Wolfgang Schäuble dem
habe ich nämlich heute genau über diesen
Punkt gesprochen habe mit ihm darüber
gesprochen ob er einen Bluff Putins mit
seiner Atom Drohung spricht und was für
ihn rote Linien sind und das ist seine
Antwort
wir dürfen uns von den Drogen nicht
einschüchtern lassen
und dann ist eben die große Kunst
die Reaktion darauf nicht einschüchtern
zu lassen
ohne gleichzeitig irgendetwas zu tun was
sich vielleicht im Sinne einer
Eskalation vermeiden lese ist das nur
rote Linie ab der wir uns dann
fundamental anders verhalten müssen
gegenüber Putin gegen bei Russland ja
klar aber dann ist der nächste Schritt
wenn man einmal nachgibt gibt man immer
nach deswegen war ja immer klar dass man
eben sich nicht erpressen lassen darf
wer einer Erpressung einmal nachgibt
wird immer weiter erpresst da habe ich
auch meine viel Bescheid daran
Erfahrungen in diesen 50 Jahren immer
wieder mal gemacht und ich bin
eigentlich gut damit gefahren zu sein
nein
ich lasse mich nicht erpressen wir haben
ja doch eine Situation in der Putin
einsehen muss wahrscheinlich ist halt
schmerzlicher
Prozess der einzig dass seine Armeen
auch nicht annähernd so leistungsfähig
ist wie er das wohl gedacht hat er hat
sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht im Februar
vorgestellt dass er fürchten muss ein
konventionellen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
verlieren zu können Mensch vorstellen
können und
jetzt ist es gar nicht mehr so
unrealistisch
jetzt ist das gar nicht mehr so
unrealistische hane dass Putin diesen
Krieg konventionell verliert sagt
Wolfgang Schäuble und trotzdem haben wir
Opfer auf beiden Seiten denn das normale
Volk in Russland will das gar nicht und
auch in der Ukraine sind die die
einfachsten schlichtesten Leute das sind
die Opfer und die müssen wir uns kümmern
deswegen frage ich hier wirklich noch
einmal Schäuble hat ja völlig recht wir
dürfen uns nicht erpressen lassen nur
die Frage ist was haben wir dagegen zu
setzen
vielleicht haben wir es ja mit einem zu
tun der jetzt in eine solche Ecke
gedrängt ist das muss man doch mal offen
sagen der gibt doch jetzt in der
gleicher Weise nach und wird um sich
lang das würde ich doch auch aber
wir haben doch in Deutschland gerade
Rot-Grün immer wieder gesagt aus dem
Pazifismus heraus Gespräche führen
Gespräche würden Diplomatie
ja aber man hätte ganz zu
statt Dämonisierung es war ja eine ganz
klare Dämonisierung für mich ist das ein
völliger Angriffskrieg nein aber warum
sind denn nicht die die noch
gesprächsfäden zu Moskau hatten es ist
sogar ein Kind Gefahren
2 Tage davor eine Woche oder vorher sah
es Herr Scholz beim Kunden der Mann hat
ihm ins Gesicht gelogen hat gesagt wir
machen nichts um zwei Tage später sind
die 100.000 marschiert sie müssen also
die Realität ist wie kommen sie doch
gerade gesagt ja herauskommen wir nur
dadurch und das ist momentan auch das
große Bemühen der Amerikaner ja dass sie
durchaus versuchen diesem an die Wand
gespielt von sich selber muss man
deutlich gesagt sagen Putin
möglicherweise eine exit Option zu
bieten denn keiner selbst die Chinesen
haben kein Interesse zu allerletzt
vielleicht das ist zu einem atomaren
Krieg kommt das heißt mittlerweile
diskut brauchen wir über Fragen die
längst auf ganz anderer Ebene verhandelt
werden das ist auch keine Frage mehr von
Olaf Scholz das ist die Frage der
Amerikaner vielleicht der Chinesen das
ist vielleicht die größte Hoffnung die
man haben könnte dass die dann das sind
Kräfte Mächte die auf Putin Einfluss
haben denken Sie an die jüngste
Konferenz wo er in der Lage war Abbitte
gegenüber den Chinesen leisten zu müssen
sagte ich sehe ihre Sorgen es gibt also
Kräfte die möglicherweise noch einen
Einfluss haben die sicherlich nicht Olaf
Scholz hat die sicherlich selbst macron
nicht hat das heißt es spielt sich auf
einer Ebene ab wo Putin irgendwie
Anzeichen machen muss überhaupt
verhandlungsbereit sein bei einer und
das darf man ja nicht vergessen bei
einer ukrainischen Regierung die
mittlerweile natürlich auch keine
Bereitschaft mehr hat ob der unzähligen
Toten hundert tausend mittlerweile in
die Hunderter 10.000 allemal Toten kaum
Bereitschaft hat diesen Krieg zu beenden
das heißt
um die Krim muss ich mal sagen dann wird
er taktische Atomwaffen einsetzen Teil
der Militärdoktrin der russischen Armee
in dem Moment in dem sie tatsächlich auf
ihr eigenes Firmen die Russen haben das
inkooperiert zurückgedrängt werden
setzen Sie nach Ihrer eigenen militären
taktischer Atomwaffen bei kleiner
Atomwaffen wie begrenzter wirken aber
jedenfalls Atomwaffen die Amerikaner
werden darauf nicht atomar reagieren
sondern konventionell warum weil atomare
Reaktionen gegenüber Russland den
Dritten Weltkrieg auslösen würde das war
noch die Amerikaner nicht das habe
ich Atomwaffen der Westen behält ihr
Atomwaffen immer schön im Schrank und
Putin setzt sie ein wir können Sie
dankenswerterweise gar nicht einsetzen
als deutsche denken
also was die Franzosen und Briten machen
weiß ich nicht die hammertum werfen die
werden Sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht
einsetzen weil die die Antwort
fürchterlich wäre
Berlin wäre in zwei Minuten zehn
Sekunden zu erreichen von den
Kurzstreckenraketen aus Kaliningrad
automatisch meine Flasche Wein aufmachen
also diese Illusion wir können kleiner
tonkrieg spielen dann halte ich für für
verkehrt ich schätze Wolfgang Schäuble
sehr wirklich waren ich habe mit ihm
lange Impressionen des Deutschen
Bundestag zusammengearbeitet aber die
Überlegung die Ukraine könnte den Krieg
gewinnen die Russen würden ihn verlieren
finde ich absurd ich finde die
Formulierung von Olaf Scholz deshalb
auch sehr intelligent der die lautet die
Russen dürfen den Krieg nicht gewinnen
was ganz anderes die dürfen den Krieg
dürfen nicht erreichen aber zu glauben
die Ukraine unterstützt vom Besten
würden die Russen jetzt aus den Gebieten
komplett wieder verdrängen bis an die
russische Staatsgrenze drin ihre aus
Ministerin komplett anders aber ich sehe
das ausdrücklich die Wolfgang Kubicki
und auch wie Olaf Scholz wobei man ja
sagen muss Olaf Scholz ist ja für diese
Aussage ausgesprochen kritisiert worden
genau
aber dann müssen was noch mal klar
machen
aber sie sagen ganz klar die Ukraine
darf diesen Krieg auch nicht gewinnen
jetzt wird die nicht gewinnen nein das
sage ich nicht sondern es geht darum und
ich finde das ist in dieser Diskussion
schon sehr gut deutlich geworden wir
sind hier nicht Manchester
Entschuldigung mal so platt sagen dafür
sind hier nicht im Sandkasten und wir
spielen nicht Krieg die Sach möglichst
viel zu ernst und es geht darum wie man
unter den gegebenen Umständen das Beste
für die Menschen Macht und zwar für die
Menschen die auch Kanonen vor der sind
auf beiden Seiten und für die zivilen
Opfer in diesem Krieg und wir wollen
natürlich dazu beitragen dass dieser
Krieg beendet wird aber richtig ist auch
und das haben wir auch beide gesagt das
ist auch ist auch Teil des was unsere
Regierung sagt natürlich werden wir
nicht fährt dann schwer dazu Flug
schaden also
ganz klar sagen dürfen was wir denken
Wolfgang Schäuble
es ist nicht mehr unrealistisch dass die
Ukraine diesen militärischen Sieg
davonfährt
zunächst erstmal klären was wir unter
Siedlung ist reden
dramatischer man hat Putin den Krieg
denn verloren das ist der entscheiden ja
genau wann hat er den Krieg verloren da
er die Annexion der Gebiete vorgenommen
hat über die von ihm bereits
annektierten Gebiete von 2014 hat er
seiner eigenen Doktrin halber den Krieg
bereits verloren wenn er diese jetzt für
ihn russischen Gebiete verloren hat ja
das heißt das ist eine ganz ganz
ungemein gefährliche Grauzone das heißt
wir finden einer Situation wo man ernst
genommen das was Putin gemacht hat
aus seiner russischen Sicht oder
jedenfalls der Sicht der Hardliner
hinter die Grenzen von 2014
machen dürfen sind ihre Gedanken unsere
Gedanken ziemlich irrelevant wenn wir
uns ernsthaft Gedanken machen sollen
über die Frage der Gefährlichkeit des
Krieges das war ihre Frage dann müssen
wir uns Gedanken über den Kopf darüber
zerbrechen das tun übrigens die Militärs
das tun alle Politiker die in den Stäben
sind wo es darum geht die Frage stellen
ab welchem Punkt verliert Putin das
Gesicht so massiv dass er es als eine
Niederlage begreift und das ist ja die
informiert das müssen wir uns bewusst
machen deswegen ich will das doch mal
lassen das ist ja manchmal nicht
unlogisch wissen Sie die das muss man
sich bewusst machen was hat Putin
gemacht die infamide stehen dahin dass
er indem er diese Gebiete und hat es
noch nie gegeben indem er vier Gebiete
annektiert und zu russischem Gebiet
gemacht hat sie gleichermaßen atomar
seinem Schutzschirm unterstellt seinem
Schutzschirm das heißt seine abwehrlogik
das ist eine gewissermaßen präventive
prävent abwehrlogitiert tätigt er sagt
wenn ihr diese Gebiete jetzt an tastet
dann bin ich in Verteidigung meiner
meines russischen Landes berechtigt das
heißt wir alle sagen nach dieser
unrechtmäßigen Abstimmung machen wir
nicht wir halten jetzt raus
haben
ganz kurz sie sind gleich wieder dran da
ich möchte das einmal klären mit der
Politikerin die dem scholzlager angehört
also was machen wir jetzt mit den
Gebieten
aber möchte innerlich wahrscheinlich
Weinen gerade aber die Hagedorn das
heißt ja von Lucke sagt gerade diese
Gebiete unterstehen jetzt im atomaren
Schutzschirm von Herrn Putin ja das
heißt
wir dürfen
moment mal moment mal also es ist schon
ein Unterschied zwischen der Krim von
2014 und den Gebieten die jetzt weil das
ist ja auch von keinem Staat anerkannt
worden diese ab ich weiß dass es ich
weiß dass das in der Logik Putins anders
ist aber ich gehe persönlich davon aus
dass die Annektion jetzt dieser Gebiete
von Europa zum Beispiel anders beurteilt
wird aber dabei geht es jetzt im Moment
gerade nicht um den Einsatz ab
die Gebiete zurückholen das zu versuchen
dabei mit unseren Waffen unterstützt
also nicht nur mit deutschen sondern mit
westlichen Waffen unterstützt sonst
könnte er ja also das wollen sie zurück
haben diese vier Region das muss ich
aber die Frage ist glaube ich ob wir das
zurückkommen wollen darum ein Zustand
anzustreben international der dazu
geeignet ist eine Grundlage für
ernsthafte Verhandlungen die dann
allerdings auch vom Putin gewollt sein
müssen herbeizuführen ich
meine dass wir da jetzt plänkeln
verstehe ich nicht denn genau das was
sie sagen ist das was ich denke und
meine denn die Frage wann ich gesagt
habe aber nein nein nein nein wir müssen
uns klar sagen unsere Diplomatie
funktioniert nicht weil Deutschland
Entschuldigung der lacht ja Herr Putin
nur genau das was Sie sagen wir müssen
uns doch jetzt angucken wer hat
überhaupt noch Einfluss auf bodinen und
zwar nicht ein bisschen rhetorisch
sondern mit einer
unterstützenden Macht zu sagen also mein
lieber so oder soll das denn sein
luca hat das ja eben ganz klar gesagt
das ist unter anderem China
und das ist natürlich die USA das sind
die Player die die eigentlichen Relevanz
haben macht
ist gar keine Frage und trotzdem ist es
gravierend sich zunächst einmal die
Perfidie und darauf habe ich einen
großen Unterschied zwischen uns beiden
gesehen die perfidi Putins bewusst zu
machen mit der hinweisschiene Art und
Weise nach 45 natürlich nicht den
Abschreckung seine Atomwaffen gebraucht
sondern faktisch in Annexion eines neuen
Gebietes als Angriffswaffen das ist das
ironische er hat sich gebietet zu eigen
gemacht die nie völkerrechtlich russisch
waren und er verteidigt sie jetzt in
angriffsmaniert mit Atomwaffen und das
ist die Gefahr der wir uns Begriffen ich
sag mal ein Beispiel sind sie so sicher
dass wenn die Ukrainer plötzlich
mariopol zurückgewinnen würden Person
zurückgewinnen würden das Putin das
nicht als Niederlage begreifen würde und
nur die Grillen da habe ich große
Zweifel das heißt ich will damit sagen
die Logik der er selber ausgesetzt ist
und ich habe übrigens sie haben doch
alle die Bilder gesehen die sind
enthemden Putin mit seinen vier Oblast
Regierenden um ihn rum ja der also fast
aus sich rausbrach und zeigte hier diese
Ukraine wird immer uns bleiben und das
heißt er sitzt ein ungemeinem Druck
ausgesetzt der meine ich nicht nur am
Rand anfängt sondern der tiefer geht und
da muss er sie sehen doch nur letzter
dass er kadirus dass er kadirus das den
größten belizisten zum generalobas
machen musste
aber nicht ganz ohne das heißt ist erst
das zeigt wie er auch Kräfte versucht
einzubinden die weit belizistischer noch
sind also ich würde ihnen zustimmen wenn
es eine Überschreitung der
demokrationslinie 24 Februar durch die
europäischen Truppen in Richtung
Separatisten Gebiete gehen würde puthead
immer noch die Chance zu sagen die
Separatisten Gebiete die seit fünf
Jahren ohnehin schon nicht mehr zur
Ukraine gehören in der
verwaltungstechnisch die russische Pässe
haben was auch immer die wir bezahlen
die haben jetzt inkompret in russischen
Staatsverband wenn das akzeptiert wird
ist der ist deswegen keine Niederlage
man wäre doch der ganze Krieg ab 24.02
obsolet
zurückzieht und damit hätte er in der
Tat den Krieg im Sinne des Rückzugs auf
den 24.09
immer weitere Eskalation und die Frage
ist wie kommen wir da raus und wenn die
Atomwaffen Drohung irgendwann wahr
gemacht wird ist es dann so dass wir in
Deutschland davor stehen und sagen
Mensch jetzt ist zu weit gegangen jetzt
müssen wir nachgehen ja aber dann ist es
zu spät
ist also klüger gibt nach dass wir in
dem Moment einknicken ist also
Alternative wäre deutsche
truppenmaschinen in Ukraine und helfen
ich stelle eine Frage
eine andere Antwort erwarten
wen wollen wir denn schicken also wir
können doch Deutschland jetzt mal ganz
weglassen wir nehmen uns ja jetzt auch
so unglaublich wichtig Deutschland
spielt überhaupt keine Rolle wir haben
weder Machtmittel noch diplomatische
Mittel und die Bundeswehr haben wir
zerstört wir können das doch nur noch
mit Geld machen ich bin ganz mit von
Luca einig es müssen diejenigen jetzt
dran und zwar so schnell wie möglich und
das ist der diplomatische Weg den muss
man ja nicht öffentlich machen aber dass
man China dazu bewegt dass man die USA
dazu bewegt das haben wir gehört das ist
es aber lassen Sie uns über die Köpfe in
Deutschland sprechen wir müssen mit
denen aus Deutschland Krise gehen die
wir haben fühlen Sie sich gut aufgehoben
nö eine zwei Sitzen mit am Tisch ja
Entschuldigung sie haben doch hier jetzt
eingeladen die
schönste Frau Hagedorn sitzt seit 20
Jahren führend im Haushaltsausschuss die
kann rechnen das ist eine vernünftige
Frau die ist doch nicht wir erleben doch
Entschuldigung wenn wir heute eine
Infantilisierung der Politik erleben
wenn wir einen Wirtschaftsminister haben
der erklärt man geht nicht Pleite
sondern man hört drei Wochen auf zu
produzieren dann sage ich die Queen ist
auch nicht tot sondern sie hat nur für
ein paar Tage aufgehört zu atmen auf
diesem Niveau bewegt sich inzwischen
deutscher Politik das ist weder Kubicki
noch Hagedorn sondern das sind Leute die
Null Bildung und Ausbildung haben die
mit abgebrochenen Studien im Bundestag
sitzen und entscheidend
seine Grünen koalitionsfreunde gegen
Herrn Hahne zu verteidigen bitte schön
ja man muss kein Abschluss nicht Studium
haben um vernünftig Politik machen zu
können wir haben den Weg wir haben in
der Vergangenheit da sagte er selbst
eine Menge hoher Akademiker gehabt
der Grünen Spitze der Grünen Minister
und Ministerin überzeugt dass die die
richtigen sind uns durch diese Krise
durch eine sehr interessante Antworten
sie mal
also jedenfalls gab es in der
Vergangenheit schon Leute die schlechter
gemacht haben als die beiden und ich
muss Robert habe nicht verteidigen er
hat gelegentlich eine Ausdrucksweise
aber doch nicht in den Ämtern Herr
Kubicki ich habe doch eben ganz klar
gesagt die Ampel hat das in meinen Augen
schwerste Erbe übernommen was es in der
deutschen der bundesdeutschen Geschichte
gab nämlich die 16 Jahre die vorher
waren haben alles verursacht was wir
heute vorfinden und jetzt finden wir
aber eine Regierung vor die das ganze
noch dilettantischer macht das verstehen
sich glaube ich nicht sie können
Entschuldigung sie haben doch eine
Galerie von Wirtschaftsministern
orthograph lambsdorf
sie sagen noch mehr und das hat ihr Buch
so eine Bestseller gemacht sie sagen die
Regierung hat den Draht zu den Menschen
konzentrieren
indem wir eine schöne Rundfahrt heute
abend machen können durch Berlin dann
zeige ich Ihnen wo die Spitzenpolitiker
wohnen wo auch die spitzenhaupt bis nach
Potsdam fahren nicht zur Frage doch
erstmal
z.B die 110 Euro das heißt
Entschuldigung Kubicki und Frau Hagedorn
die geerdet sind in Norddeutschland
haben doch den Kontakt zur Bevölkerung
wer hat denn heute noch wenn sie mit
Blaulicht Kolonnen hier durch Berlin
fahren den Kontakt zur Bevölkerung ich
hätte ihn jetzt am liebsten den
Taxifahrer mitgebracht der mich hier
eben hergefahren hat ich habe die
Quittung dabei sie können ihn einladen
das war für mich wieder eine erhellende
Geschichte weil die Leute sind
verzweifelt weil wir von einer
Parallelgesellschaft
passiert werden die die den Draht zum
Volk ganz normal es ist eine historisch
das werden wir doch wohl alle gemeinsam
so sehen eine historisch einmalig
belastende Situation nur eine kleine
parallele als sie sich ich fand sogar am
Anfang durchaus in christlicher Hinsicht
nachvollziehbar in der corona-frage sehr
zu wollen übrigens ähnlich wie Herr
Kubicki ich sag mal hier sitzen zwei wie
sagt man so ein freie Radikale das ist
sind ja in einer harte Attacke uns
gehört uns geht
hier gewissermaßen die Demokratie
verloren wir sind am Ende des
Rechtsstaats so sinngemäß heute würden
wir uns alle zwei Jahre gerne
zurückbeamen weil wir plötzlich
realisieren diese Krise die corona-krise
die wir damals für die größte Krise seit
45 gehalten haben ist ein ich will nicht
sagen Nullung aber ist mit dem was wir
gegen vergleichen überhaupt nicht weg
vergleichen
wir müssen uns nicht bedauer eins das
sage ich ganz ehrlich wir haben nur
diese Regierung ich sage mal ganz
ehrlich wir haben die Regierung die das
Volk verdient und das ist ja eigentlich
ja das ist leider
ist auch die Haltung ich habe sie nie
gesehen
wir haben gerade wir sind alle Fragen
wir sind sogar alle beteiligt deswegen
nehme ich
am Ende so naja wir haben aber wir haben
aber ein Struktur ja haben sie recht da
dürfen ein strukturelles Problem und das
ist viel gravierender wir haben erstens
sehr viele ich sag mal bewusst frei
Radikale die am Rand stehen das ist sie
würden sich heute Herr Hannes sag ich
mal ganz ehrlich als alter ZDF Mann so
nicht mehr einstellen weil es gibt doch
bei Kubicki nur Kubicki als Beispiel ist
ein wunderbarer Talkshow Gast aber ich
bedauer ist dass zum Beispiel Kubicki
auch in der Art und Weise wie er bei den
Leuten ist nie ein Amt in einer
Regierung übernommen hat Kubicki hat
sich immer klar in Position gehalten wo
es das kann man gut finden das ist ja
löblich aber es wäre mal vernünftig
gewesen dass die Leute die ja das egal
den hat er vielleicht manchmal zu dir
ausgesucht dann aber ist doch egal es
gibt Leute das ist ein Teil des Problem
dass wir zum Teil tatsächlich die ich
denke auch
gelassen worden
in welcher Situation wir uns heute
befinden ich hätte mich äh 22 21 an das
entschieden definitiv dann hätten sie
mit regiert
aber das können sie doch jetzt noch
sagen also erst recht nach der Wahl
gestern Abend nehmen sie aufs Handy in
die Hand oder treffen sich mit der
Lindner heute Abend und sagen Sie nein
also
genauerweise hätte jetzt ja in einer
Stunde jetzt komme ich die strukturelle
Problematik wir sind in der größten
Krise der Republik wir haben aber eine
Koalition
bisher schön
wir haben einen strukturelles Problem
das ist viel dramatischer wir haben in
der größten Krise drei Parteien drei
Parteien drei Parteien drei Parteien die
bis zum gestrigen Abend bekommen
bis zum gestrigen Abend eine FDP erlebt
haben die der Meinung war nach der
ziemlich niederschmetternden 14
Landtagswahl Niederlage sondern gleich
nein war wir werden unseren Kurs der
Opposition in der Regierung noch
radikalisieren ich habe noch keine
Berliner Runde erlebt derart die gestern
Abend als der Generalsekretär der FDP
den beiden Koalitionspartnern regelrecht
den federhandschuhen geschmissen hat und
gesagt hat wir kommen hier nicht vor wir
werden dass der heute hat Christian
Lindner zum Glück das sage ich bewusst
erheblich Kreide gefressen weil wenn
diese Regierung jetzt nicht in der
hochproblematischen Dreierkonstellation
die da ist die gab es früher nicht das
ist das ist eine strukturelle
Problematik wenn sie nicht geschlossen
auftritt und das nächste Jahr nutzt wo
wir ja wirklich ein Jahr lang keine
richtigen Landtagswahl mehr haben
ihre politische Ausrichtung wir sind ja
völlig einer Meinung das Problem ist nur
das einige unserer Koalitionspartner
genau dieses Prinzip nicht beherrschen
ich höre immer wieder ich höre immer
wieder
schöne neue Forderung wir wollen mehr
Geld für die Bildung und die FDP muss
sie besorgen Christian Lindner muss das
Geld besorgen wir brauchen ein neues
Sondervermögen zur Stützung der sozialen
Ungleichheit die FDP muss das Geld
besorgen wir brauchen 14 Milliarden
deutschen mindestens Opfer die FDP muss
das Geld ja nein so so funktioniert das
Spiel nicht dass sie einen überfordern
und sagen wir wären wir wären die guten
und f aber sie tun sich gerade leid
wir sind doch selbst Schuld an dem was
also wird niemanden niemand anders als
wir sind an den
Wahlergebnisse müssen
in der immer der lauteste sich
durchsetzt jetzt noch gar nicht laut
antwortet einmal Herrn Kubicki der ja
sich hier erstmal als opfergerät jetzt
sagt er dann doch ein bisschen selber
warum behandeln Sie warum behandeln Sie
die Partei von hankovic in der Koalition
so schlecht dass die da nur abstinkt
nein das tun wir gar nicht aber Fakt ist
natürlich wir haben ein
Koalitionsvertrag geschlossen im letzten
Jahr und ich fand das haben diese drei
sehr unterschiedlichen Fraktion absolut
gut aber den halten sie sich nicht sagt
er jetzt darf ich mal ausmachen so wir
haben ein Koalitionsvertrag gemacht in
atemberaubend schneller Zeit auch in
großer Solidität alle aufeinander
zugegangen der war getragen von dem
ansinnleben und leben lassen wir wollen
alle dass wir wollen nicht so tun als
würden wir alle vermischt werden nein
wir sind drei verschiedene Parteien alle
mit ihren eigenen Profilen und wir
wollen gemeinsam gut regieren so und das
was wir verabredet haben daran halten
wir uns auch daran halten wir uns auch
bis heute allerdings ist es so dass sich
die Welt seit dem 24 Februar absolut
geändert hat ich habe es ja vorhin schon
einmal kurz erwähnt wir sind jetzt auf
einmal die erste Regierung die Waffen in
Kriegsgebiete liefert das hat es wohl in
die gegebenen stand übrigens natürlich
auch nicht in unserem Koalitionsvertrag
da stand auch nicht drin wir machen 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen aber gut
regieren tun sie immer aber wir haben es
gemacht und das ist doch eine Stärke und
keine Schwäche dieser Regierung einen
kleinen Augen moment mal aber das
bedeutet natürlich wissen Sie ich stehe
ja für die Schuldenbremse schon per
Steinbrück hat die Schuldenbremse
Einheit von ich habe sie selbst mit in
die Verfassung eingeführt so stehe ich
drauf sie steht in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag es steht auch da drin
wir erhöhen keine Steuern das haben wir
alles miteinander vereinbart aber dann
kam der 24 februar und dann kam eine
Situation die uns vor so eklatante
Herausforderungen stellt dass man
richtig regieren muss
so viele Milliarden ich muss in die Hand
nehmen tun es ja auch das kommt aber das
ist unter den vereinbarten Bedingungen
einfach eine große Herausforderung da
muss man so ehrlich sein denn die
Verfassung wollen wir auch nicht brechen
und das ist nicht die Schuld von der FDP
und nicht der SPD sondern wir versuchen
das Beste gemeinsame auszumachen viel zu
vernünftig Liebe Frage
oh nein lieber Herr Kubicki sie haben
eben gesagt was Herr Lindner alles tun
muss Herr Lindner wird gefragt wo die
Mitarbeiter wissen Sie wer das alles
bezahl und das sind die Leute die uns
jetzt zuhören oder Platz mehr der Kragen
die Menschen die uns zuhören im Lande
die müssen es bezahlen ja und sie sind
nicht in der Lage mit diesem Geld so
umzugehen dass die Leute begreifen warum
sie so tun das hat nichts mit
Kommunikation
damit wie sie aktuell mit den Kosten auf
morgen der Inflation allein gelassen
werden
schöne Formulierung ist falsch ja
versucht zu begreifen Koalition
funktionieren nicht wenn einer der
Koalitionspartner unabhängig
gemacht
der Lindner gibt das Geld aus der Witz
ja gerade zusammenhalten sondern unsere
Koalitionspartner insbesondere unsere
grünen Freunde kommen mit regelmäßig
neuen Forderungen
das ja umsetzen
zu den konkreten Problemen den
explodierenden Energiekosten der
Inflation mit den mit der sich viele
Deutsche allein gelassen fühlen der
Grund der Frage glaube ich daran dass
die Regierung meine konkreten Probleme
löst oder nicht und die meisten sagen
bei der FDP glaube ich nicht nur bei der
FDP nicht ich glaube momentan
Demokratie
gestern grün und der SPD gewesen
insgesamt an Niedersachsen verloren
nicht verloren nein nein nein ihr
Vertrauen verbunden warum warum laufen
der ganz kurz warum laufen wir machen
Menschen warum laufen der FDP die
Menschen davon und warum laufen der FDP
die Menschen davon nämlich 40.000
gestern Niedersachsen zack zu AFD rüber
ja weil sie weil sie im Protest
ausdrücken wollen die gehen auch
nichtwählerschaft die sagen einfach wir
trauen diese Regierung und
bedauerlicherweise die bürgerlichen
Wähler der FDP in dieser Regierung nicht
mehr zu dass die Probleme wirklich
gelöst werden können die trauen uns die
Kraft nicht zu beispielsweise bei der
Frage der Energiepreise dafür sorgen zu
tragen dass wir unsere eigenen
heimischen Ressourcen nutzen die haben
sich der bundeswirtschaft mit der stellt
sie hin mit Training in den Augen und
sagt wie unmoralisch dass das hier mal
keiner so viel Geld haben wollte die
lngas wir haben selbst genug Gas in der
Nordsee gab es ein bisschen
Koalitionsvertrag sogar vereinbart das
ist gefördert werden soll und wir nutzen
unsere eigenen Ressourcen sie haben ja
zwei Probleme das ist ja das eigentliche
Grundproblem sie haben Verlust in alle
Richtungen und das ist das Problem keine
Verluste in Richtung SPD und Grüne sie
haben in alle Richtungen nein gucken sie
auf der Bundesebene haben sie in alle
Richtungen Verlust und es geht ja nicht
nur um das Land es ist ja tatsächlich so
und da muss man ihm schon zustimmen die
gesamte Ampel hat verloren wir hatten
gestern ein Land
zu viel über Partei Strategien und
Politik ich will doch gar nicht wissen
Punkt wir haben doch gerade jetzt reden
das Problem von dieser Koalition besteht
darin dass Sie obwohl Sie uns eine
Zeitenwende verkündet hat die übrigens
im Kern nur bedeutet eine ganz konkret
dass man plötzlich auf lange lange Sicht
100 Milliarden in die Bundeswehr steckt
was konkret mit der Bewaffnung der
Ukraine sehr wenig zu tun hat deswegen
auch Osteuropa nicht so sie hat vor
allem und das ist eigentlich wo sie hat
innenpolitisch bis heute keine neue
geschäftsgrund gefunden sie hat keine
Klarheit
das Problem ist nur auch die FDP hat und
das ist mein glaube ich das ist für
viele in der bevölkerungsgrundproblem
hat bisher keine neue Haltung gefunden
sie ist in absoluter
Verteidigungsposition oder
Oppositionspolitik in der Regierung es
hört doch Lindner gestern sogar noch
selber gesagt das ist ja ganz egal
indem er angetreten ist übrigens von
Anfang an übrigens nicht zuletzt in der
Bild-Zeitung immer wieder bekräftigt mit
den Aussagen war die wir sind die Mitte
gegen zwei linke Parteien
machen so und jetzt kommt der
entscheidende Punkt ja genau das geht
sogar noch weiter und heute hat aber
nicht wesentlich anders geholt weil er
realisiert hat bei der realisierte dass
wir gestern übrigens ihre
Generalsekretär sie tendenziell auch sie
waren für ihre Verhältnisse recht
zurückgehalten wie ich finde der
Kernsatz war der fremdeln mit dieser
Koalition
und die Frage fragedorn Frau Hagedorn
die Frage gemeinsam
Fragen
ja aber dann müssen Sie auch mal auf die
Frage antworten
und zwar die Frage wie gewinnen wir das
Vertrauen hat es gerade eindrucksvoll
geschildert wie erschüttert das
Vertrauen ist die Umfragen stützen das
im Moment das ist nicht nur der
Vermutung oder Hannes Privatmeinung
privat Eindruck wie gewinnen wir das
Vertrauen zurück kriegen wir das
schaffen wir das durch Geld verteilen
nein nicht durch Geld verteilen aber ich
bin fest davon überzeugt dass wir das
schaffen und ich will darauf ich will
darauf hinweisen dass ich ja seit 20 im
Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages bin
und das deshalb kann ich mich an 2829
erinnern zum Beispiel und wir sind durch
diese Finanz also Klaus Rickling der ja
demnächst aufhört als esm-chef hat
gerade vorgestellt vor wenigen Tagen
großes Interview dazu gegeben und
Rückblick behalten auf 2829 und hat noch
mal deutlich gemacht wie existenziell
dramatisch diese Krise eigentlich war
das haben ganz viele Menschen überhaupt
nicht mehr auf dem Schirm weil sie
denken wir haben es ja gelöst haben wir
ja und wir sind besser durch diese Krise
gekommen übrigens als alle
Nachbarstaaten und er hat daran erinnert
dass es uns so stark hätte erwischen
können dass das Europa dass wir heute
haben nicht das gewesen wäre wenn es uns
nicht gefällt wird
kein spd-werbeblock die Kanzlerin hieß
damals Angela Merkel der Steinbrück
der Steinbrück war ihr Finanzminister
aber wir haben ja hinterher weitere
Krisen gehabt wenn wir daran denken 2015
als die Flüchtlinge gekommen sind wenn
wir daran denken dann die
corona-pandemie und in all den Zeiten
habe ich in verschiedenen Regierungen
mitgearbeitet und muss sagen die waren
alle ziemlich bedrohlich und jetzt und
die waren alle ziemlich bedrohlich aber
wir haben es ganz gut gemanagt und darum
ganz kurze Pause an der Stelle füllen
bei Ihnen Frau Hagedorn und bei Ihnen
Herr von Luca einmal das Wasser nach sie
kriegen wir auch was neues zu trinken
was immer Sie sich wünschen und dann
sprechen wir hier darüber wie wir durch
diesen Winter kommen über die Ängste die
in Deutschland herrschen die ihr hane
gerade schon benannt hat und was wir
eigentlich noch hier am Tisch für
Lösungen anzubieten haben gleich noch
eine ganz kurze Pause
zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen in
dieser Gaskrise in dieser Energiekrise
und ja bei explodierenden Kosten bei
denen wir alle nicht bei den Rechnungen
nicht mehr wissen wohin das noch führt
und der Regierung die sagt na im
Dezember könnt ihr zumindest jetzt
erstmal ordentlich heizen da übernehmen
wir die Rechnung für euch komplett den
Abschlag ihr Weg ist es richtig ich
gucke mir erstmal die Vorschläge genau
an und frage nach der technischen
Umsetzung das wird gar nicht so ganz
einfach werden weil ich gar nicht weiß
als Versorger momentan wer auf der
anderen Seite meine Rechnung sitzt ob
das jemand ist der zwei Swimmingpool hat
oder ob das jemand ist der in einem
Mehrfamilienhaus wohnt wobei dann der
Verwalter des Mehrfamilienhauses auch
dann immer selbst noch zuordnen muss
welche einzelne Betrag fällt entfällt
eigentlich auf die jeweils dort wohnende
Parteien sich technische Herausforderung
was ich glaube ich glaube wir sind an
der Phase wo wir all in Spielen müssen
alles was wir in Ressourcen zur
Verfügung stellen können eine Energie
Ressourcen aus dem eigenen Land muss
sofort umgesetzt werden nur dann senken
wir die Preise momentan dämpfen wir die
Preise durch Steuermittel das können wir
auf Dauer nicht durchhalten und wenn die
Versorger alle aus also unsere Energie
Anbieter alle im Ausland sitzen können
die mit uns wildes auch spielen was man
sozusagen
können den wir zahlen müssen weil wir
keine Alternativen werden also alles was
wir haben all in das heißt kernecki
solange es nötig ist das heißt eigene
Gas Ressourcen nutzen wenn es möglich
ist das heißt auch schiefergasfördern in
Deutschland es kann nicht unmoralischer
sein bei uns als in USA abgesehen davon
dass wir dass wir Milliardenbetrag an
Wertschöpfung ins Ausland transportieren
statt das bei uns selbst zu lassen und
das wird ein Riesenproblem werden was
uns nicht nur ein oder zwei Jahre
begleiten wird dann mehrere Jahre also
kontraproduktiv sagte das alles mit
Steuergeld alles mit Steuergeld
zuzuschütten und den Preis zu dämpfen im
Dezember zumindest war Hagedorn das
machen im Moment ganz offensichtlich gar
keine Alternative wenn wir in diesem
Land und in diesem Winter für Stabilität
sorgen wollen als Regierung und dafür
gibt es für mich überhaupt gar keine
Alternative das haben wir in der
corona-pandemie im übrigen auch so
gemacht und das ist auch richtig so weil
die Menschen die machen sich doch Sorgen
ich werde mit dem mit dem Begriff Angst
immer etwas
vorsichtig weil Angst wirklich nicht gut
ist nicht heilt nicht heilsam aber alle
Menschen haben totale Sorgen und es ist
unser gottverdammter Job sie ihn zu
nehmen im Rahmen ermöglicht das konkrete
Vorsteuerung oder die ganzen moment mal
also eigentlich war die Frage ja nach
den Vorschlägen der gastpreiskommission
von heute
angucken das würde ich auch gerne machen
aber Fakt ist natürlich ist es ein
zweigeteilter Vorschlag auf der einen
Seite mit einer mit Barmitteln sozusagen
im Dezember und zwar warum weil das
schnell geht und in der corona-pandemie
wir müssen doch Dinge machen die schnell
gehen wir haben doch auch die drei die
ersten beiden Hilfspakete die wir in
dieser Regierung schon geschnürt haben
haben wir doch auch so angelegt dass sie
zum Beispiel über die arbeitge die
energiepauschale ausgezahlt wurden oder
über die Familienkassen des Kindergeld
oder so also dass sie ohne Beantragung
ohne Widerspruch ohne diesen ganzen
bürokratischen Öl wirklich bei den
Menschen sondern
bei der zentralen Frage von Herrn
kopiekade wie stehen sie denn dazu zu
dem Fracking
Vorschlag ich halte Fracking für nicht
die richtige Lösung aber er müsste dann
auch sagen wann wir damit hätten
anfangen sollen weil zu glauben dass wir
da jetzt mit Anfang und im nächsten Jahr
fördern wir dann fördern wir dann
frechengast das ist komplett utopisch
genau
moment mal moment mal also genauso wie
ich ja auch den Vorschlag aus der FDP
gehört habe wir sollen jetzt neue
Atomkraftwerke bauen ja wann sollen die
denn ans Netz gehen 20 40 oder was das
hilft uns im Moment gar nicht richtig
ist sie vor sechsmal einen Moment fangen
Moment nein nein also wir haben die
Gaslager jetzt nahezu voll das ist ein
riesen Erfolg wir drücken auf die Tube
bei den erneuerbaren Energien das ist
sowieso das allerwichtigste wir drücken
auf die Tube bei LNG das haben wir alles
die vorherigen Regierung nicht gemacht
ihr schnellstmöglich unsere
energiebilanzprozesse alles tun sie
alles wir werden sie auch übrigens wir
werden sie übrigens auch verbessern
dadurch wir wollen ja auch mehr
energieeffizien
glaube ich in dieser Regierung nicht
miteinander hinkriegen das ist nämlich
die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen zu
lassen als drei Monate aber das ist der
Punkt er möchte die Preise nicht nur mit
Steuergeld senken und sie sagen sehr
viele Beispiele genannt aber sie tun
nicht alles um den Preis durch nein wir
machen also
durch eine längere Laufzeit
erklären nein aber Moment dann müssen
sie mal die Frage beantworten was wenn
wir jetzt die Ampel bei Fracking auf
Grün stellen wann wir dann das erste
die Frage war und das haben Experten
hier am Tisch gesagt dass sie das in
sechs Monaten oder in neun Monaten
hinbekommen hätten wenn sie damit längst
gestartet haben
darf ich was zurücktragen
sehr wichtig man muss sich schon fragen
auch wenn Herr Kubicki sagt wir sollen
alles flott machen und sie insolvenieren
haben sie alles gemacht haben sie alles
gemacht wir leben noch in der Demokratie
so die grundsätzliche Frage die auch ein
Demos zu entscheiden hätte ob er
beispielsweise AKWs länger laufen will
hätte die FDP sich beispielsweise hätte
sich ja toll hätte die FDP sich
beispielsweise mal initiiert durch die
Bild-Zeitung beispielsweise
Niedersachsen trauen sollen wir machen
Fracking ich wüsste nicht dass sie das
mit vehements gemacht hat weil natürlich
viele Menschen durchaus keine allzu
großen Sympathien gegenwärtig dafür
haben wir haben ganz andere Gründe die
wir nehmen weiter weiter machen sollten
wir haben auch gut Veranlassung nach und
nach wie vor weiter in Teilen Energie zu
sparen selbst die Bild-Zeitung selbst
die Bild-Zeitung mit zu meiner großen
Freude durfte ich erleben brachte vor
wenigen Tagen eine grüne Bild Richtung
nachdem sie jegliche politische
Anstrengung Menschen anzuhalten zu
sparen Energie zu sparen als den
übergriffigen Staat denunziert hat hat
die Bild-Zeitung haben dieselbe haben
sie selber eine Bild-Zeitung gemacht bei
der Sie gesagt haben wir wollen Ihnen
das finde ich völlig richtig weil wir
uns eines bewusst machen müssen wir
müssen mehr Energie da sind wir ja bei
einer sind wir ja beieinander wir
brauchen mehr Energie wir brauchen
Unabhängigkeit ich halte es deswegen
auch von Robert habe für sehr unklug
dass er diesen
Mittelweg gegangen ist um in kurzer Zeit
dann auch feststellen zu müssen wir
müssen die Dinge halten die zwei oder
meinetwegen auch drei Achse ist aber
wir dürfen nicht verzichten darauf trotz
alledem auch durch Einsparung aus einer
Krise zu kommen wo die beides brauchen
nicht immer ganz klar gewesen
ja keine Mehrheit bekommen
wahrscheinlich und bei den
Atomkraftwerken möglicherweise gibt es
deutlich fürchte ich befürchtet das auch
pleitewellen ja das auch privat bleiben
keine Mehrheit hätten aber lieber
teilweise es ist doch wir leben doch in
einem Land das ist wissen sie diese
Diskussion ich diskutiere für mein Leben
gerne aber ich denke an die Leute die
uns zuhören verstehen sie das ist doch
ein Wahnsinn wir moralisieren in einer
hochmoral das ist das Einzige was wir
noch exportieren aus Deutschland
deutschland Deutschland über alles an
deutschen Wesen soll alles genesen das
ist doch die neue Nationalhymne jetzt
platzt mir der Kragen wir merken
natürlich weil ich nicht von Strukturen
Rede und was auch immer wir machen jetzt
lustig über ein Hase aber er sagt also
jetzt kommt Ihre Frage wir können doch
in einer unfassbaren Doppelmoral nicht
das Fracking verdammen und kaufen das
Fracking Gas aus Amerika wir können
nicht Putin verdammen und verkaufen und
kaufen das Gas was über einzige von
Indien und ein wer weiß was kommt
unterwegs moralisch gereinigt dir ein
wir verdammen die Atomkraftwerke und
Kaufen von Frankreich und von allen
Ländern Atomstrom liegen Sie genau zu
den Leuten
Frau Hagedorn hat eben völlig richtig
gesagt wir haben die corona-krise gehabt
das war was neues jetzt haben wir diese
Kriegsgeschichte ist eigentlich ja auch
was Neues aber wir haben trotzdem bei
Corona zwei Jahre wir haben nach einem
Jahr nicht gehört auf die Kinderärzte
nicht gehört auf die Gerontologen nicht
gehört auf die die über die Einsamkeit
der alten und so weiter
gepflegt haben auf wen muss man oh nein
genau und jetzt sind wir bei einem Punkt
und sagen ach wissen Sie das muss jetzt
erst strukturell geklärt werden und so
weiter bis wir das mit dieser
Kriegsgeschichte machen nein wir müssen
doch so schnell wie möglich aus
Erfahrungen lernen
wir haben bei Corona versagt bin ich der
Überzeugung
was haben Leute investieren
müssen
Herr Hahne wirft ihn auch ihnen
Doppelmoral vor und führt an
beispielsweise ihre Position zum Flecken
ihre Position zu Atomkraftwerken
ja ist falsch ich ja will ich ja gerne
begründen also Atomkraft ich bin
Atomkraftgegnerin da komme ich her und
ich halte es gegenüber meinen Kindern
und gegenüber meinen Enkelkindern für
die gefährlichste Energieform überhaupt
wir haben das wir haben das
Endlagerproblem immer noch nicht gelöst
und es ist übrigens auch die teuerste
Energie sie wurde in Deutschland
weil sie sagten gefährlich also gerade
etwas zum Doppel zur Doppelkinn das ist
ja möglicherweise auch doppelt sagen es
ist gefährlich
das in den vier Jahren in denen ich
nicht mitregiert habe als
Sozialdemokratin von 2009 bis 2013 die
CDU und die FDP die Laufzeiten
verlängert haben obwohl es vorher ein
Vertrag gab und der Rot-Grün und wenn
wir diesen Vertrag einfach behalten
hätten den haben nämlich die vier
Energie monopolis wenn ich sie mal so
nennen darf unterschrieben und darum war
es ein Vertrag und der war nicht darauf
konnte hätte man nicht erfolgversprechen
klagen können dann wurden die Laufzeiten
verlängert im Oktober 2010 und damit
wurde dieser Vertrag gekündigt und ein
halbes Jahr später waren Fukushima und
die gleiche Regierung hat gesagt ups das
ist ja alles ganz gefährlich jetzt reden
wir mal eben kurz um ich hätte die
letzten nicht gebraucht tschernobyl hat
mir eigentlich gereicht und nur dadurch
nur dadurch haben wir den vier
Energiekonzern den klargewicht also wir
haben hier ja ein Juristen am Tisch der
weiß das besser als ich noch aber ich
kann mich gut erinnern wir haben
Verfassungsklage eingereicht die haben
sich damit durchgesetzt welcher
Finanzminister musste das bezahlen die
Milliarden an Regress an die viereckigen
Steuerzahler mussten
Steuerzahler hat bezahlt die
Steuererklärung auf die Schultern aber
sagen auch das ist aus meiner Sicht
doppelmoralisch und vor dem Hintergrund
zu glauben dass uns wenn wir jetzt die
Laufzeiten wenn wir jetzt die Laufzeiten
was ja geeint ist in dieser Regierung
wenn wir die auf Standby ein paar Monate
weiter halten das ist okay halten Sie
darüber hinaus läuft dann müssen neue
Brennstäbe beschaffen dass eine völlig
andere Hausnummer und damit machen wir
wieder das fast der Pandora auch und das
wird es aus meiner Sicht in dieser
Regierung mit der SPD und mit den Grünen
nicht gehen ganz kurz aber das was
halten genau
halten Sie diese Position die sie gerade
geschildert haben durch wenn sie durch
ihren Wahlkreis gehen und die Leute
zeigen Ihnen Ihre Gastgeschenke wir sind
pleite ja wir können
Schleswig-Holstein geht es gibt ganz
viele Menschen die das richtig finden
dass wir an dieser Stelle stark sind und
es ist ja nicht so dass das Wohl und
Wehe an der Atomkraft hängen würde ich
sagen ich komme schließlich also wir
beide kommen Schleswig-Holstein die
erste Windmühle wurde von der Ingelheim
Regierung Anfang der 30er Jahren
ich möchte jemanden sagen
ich glaube dass wir genau mit dieser
Festlegung gerade dabei sind die AFD
ziemlich stark natürlich machen sie
meine nicht aber man muss immer deutlich
sagen
jetzt kann ich nur sagen wenn so
primitiv diskutiert wird das jetzt ein
Locke zu mir sagt ich würde mit meinen
Äußerungen die AFD stark machen nein ich
kämpfe hier darum das Vertrauen
zurückzubringen
von der ersten Stunde
verstanden
Aussagen die Furcht nicht davon nehmen
dass sie Winter frieren oder keinen
Strom mehr
ich sage Ihnen das in dem Moment die mir
das erste mal im Blackout haben
verschwinden alle ihre Bedenken weil sie
bei dem die Menschen in die Bude
einrennen das erste Mal wenn die Leute
zu Hause keinen Gas mehr keine Heizung
mehr bekommen weil die über die Werke
abgeschaltet
viel Vergnügen die diese diese
demokratische Regierung hat dann versagt
und wie wir treiben das ist ja mit
dieser Festlegung wir treiben als
demokratische Parteien die Menschen in
die Verzweiflung damit zur AFD die
werden am Ende des Monats hören sie auf
mich dann werden die ohne dass sie was
tun müssen genauso stark seinen Umfragen
wie SPD garantiert was passiert
eigentlich wenn du in diesem Land wenn
in diesem Land das Licht sehen sie
gleich dran wenn in diesem Land das
Licht ausgeht wenn der Strom weg ist
auch darüber habe ich heute kurz mit
Wolfgang Schäuble gesprochen dass seine
Antwort
und und dann sieht man halt ein Pullover
an und wenn man den zweiten Pullover
anzieht dann geht es auch Strom ist
nicht mehr selbstverständlich das Licht
oben ist schon selbstverständlich aber
es kann auch mal ausfallen ja deswegen
hat man den Zweifel auch ein paar Kerzen
und ein paar Streichhölzer zu Hause und
dann ist natürlich wichtig dass man weiß
wo die sind falls es mal dunkel wird im
Dunkeln suchen ist auch schwierig dann
sieht man halt ein Pullover
anziehen wurde für den genau gleichen
Satz
hingerichtet ich kann ja mit Schäuble
jetzt nicht reden ich schätze ihn über
alle Maßen die haben eng auch persönlich
miteinander zu tun gehabt aber wissen
Sie ich sage Ihnen mal ich bin ja nun
selbst ein alter weißer Mann aber ich
kann es nicht mehr ertragen wie Leute
aus gesicherten Positionen Professoren
Politiker Journalisten die ganz
wunderbar
gesteiner Populismus toll gestellt sind
und mir ist es völlig egal
an der Stelle wir können das halt nicht
lange so bezahlen wir müssen es denen
geben die ist wirklich toll hat sich
zumindest alle anderen müssen sich ein
Pullover übertragen
überhaupt noch mal ein Verhältnis
herzustellen zu Zeiten in denen es
möglich war Debatten über die Frage ob
man ein Zimmer auch mit 19 mit 20 Grad
bewohnen kann zu sagen dann zieht man
sich einen Pullover über dieses Rand
Land ist so unermesslich reich
verglichen mit anderen Zeiten das
Kandidaten ich lebe in Deutschland ja
reden sie leben in Wilmersdorf glaube
wäre doch mal die gibt's doch gar nicht
die Frage wäre doch mal die bevor
Menschen wir haben übrigens ich finde
das bemerkenswert die uns hier
gewissermaßen Doppelmoral oder
jedenfalls in die Runde schmeißen
niemand argumentiert Moralin saurer als
Herr Hahne sollten Sie sich schon
bewusst morgen ich bin früher in dieser
Populismus der da lautet guckt euch
diese unsäglichen Politiker an keine
bodenhaft das ist wirklich gesagt das
ist der Inbegriff dessen was die
populistische Machart ist und das sollte
man durchaus an diesem Punkt auch so zur
Geltung bringen dafür verkauft er ja
seine Bücher glänzen die heißen auch
alle Schluss mit und Schluss ja und gut
raus und Wut draußen das ist Definition
das ist der hochbürger das haben sie vor
20 Jahren geschrieben da waren sie noch
biblisch aber ich will damit sagen ich
will damit sagen wir müssen uns schon
mal die Problematik bewusst machen diese
hält diese Regierung versucht ja
händeringend in weiten Teilen
Energieformen Flotte gucken sich doch
mal zwei Herren dann ist es schade
machen wir die nächste weiter
passiert die Fortsetzung folgt in der
Runde wenn sie alle mit dabei sind ja
gerne
überlegt
ganz kurzes Schlusswort gibt es in
diesen ernsten Zeiten einmal ganz kurz
nachdenklich und vielleicht doch
fröhlich am Ende richtig es gibt noch
viel zu lachen für Wolfgang Kubicki in
diesen ernsten Zeiten also gestern hat
heute nicht aber ansonsten schon ich bin
ein sehr grundoptimistischer Mensch ich
glaube auch wir können das schaffen wenn
wir alle Ressourcen die wir haben nutzen
das müssen wir nur tun und bei manchen
dauert die Überlegung ein bisschen
länger als bei anderen ich habe
Verständnis dass man Zeit braucht von
Positionen abzurücken aber wir haben
nicht mehr sehr viel Zeit weil ich
glaube dass die Populisten sonst
wirklich die Oberhand gewinnen das ist
das heißt die FDP wird sie ab jetzt
offenbar auch ändern Wolfgang Kubicki
vielen Dank Peter Hahne Bettina Hagedorn
danke und Albrecht von Duke herzlichen
Dank und jetzt hören wir gemeinsam
Wolfgang Schäuble zu mit dem ich über
all diese Themen auch gesprochen und
teilweise auch gestritten haben
seine Drohung hat Putin in der Regel
wahrgemacht das heißt wir können jetzt
gerade nicht so blauäugig zu sein und
sagen naja der droht nur mit seinen
Nuklearwaffen er wird sie aber nie
einsetzen was machen wir eigentlich was
macht eigentlich der Westen wenn er sie
einsetzt wir dürfen uns von den Drogen
nicht einschüchtern lassen
und dann ist eben die große Kunst
die Reaktion darauf nicht einschüchtern
zu lassen
ohne gleichzeitig irgendetwas zu tun was
sich vom vielleicht im Sinne einer
Eskalation vermeiden lese ist das nur
rote Linie ab der wir uns dann
fundamental anders verhalten müssen
gegenüber Putin gegen Russland ja klar
aber dann ist der nächste Schritt wenn
man einmal nachgibt gibt man immer nach
deswegen war ja immer klar dass man eben
sich nicht erpressen lassen darf wer
einer Erpressung einmal nachgibt wird
immer weiter erpresst da habe ich auch
meine viel bescheideneren Erfahrungen in
diesen 50 Jahren immer wieder mal
gemacht und ich bin eigentlich gut damit
gefahren zu sagen nein
ich lasse mich nicht erpressen wir haben
ja doch eine Situation in der Putin
einsehen muss wahrscheinlich ist halt
schmerzlicher
Prozess der einzig dass seine Armeen
auch nicht annähernd so leistungsfähig
ist wie er das wohl gedacht hat er hat
sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht im Februar
vorgestellt dass er fürchten muss sein
konventionellen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
verlieren zu können Mensch vorstellen
können und
jetzt ist es gar nicht mehr so
unrealistisch die kritisieren auch die
Bürger die sich versorgen lassen wollen
von dem Staat die sozusagen nur
Erwartungen haben und das finde ich
völlig in Ordnung und ich meine das
Entscheidende ist dass die Menschen das
Gefühl haben müssen es geht fair zu es
wird den geholfen die es wirklich
brauchen man muss den Menschen schon
sagen ja
das wird schwierig und dann muss man
eben sagen was geht und was nicht geht
man kann den Menschen nicht ersparen
dass die Energie sehr viel teurer wird
aber man kann natürlich sagen gut die
die das nicht mehr schaffen können
den wird geholfen wir empfinden sie das
nach all den Jahrzehnten Wohlstand dass
wir über Blackouts sprechen und über
kalte Wohnungen das ist nicht
selbstverständlich es ist doch gut und
dann sieht man halt ein Pullover an und
wenn man einen zweiten Pullover anzieht
dann geht es auch wir hatten übrigens
schon mal in den 70er Jahren
Helmut Schmidt war Bundeskanzler hatten
wir ja auch eine Energiekrise da ist
auch schon damals in öffentlichen
Gebäuden ich glaube die Raumtemperaturen
Washington ist damals auf 17 Grad
festgelegt worden und die mussten auch
der amerikanische Präsident hat
jedenfalls symbolisch ein Pullunder
angezogen Strom ist nicht mehr
selbstverständlich das Licht Schrauben
ist schon selbstverständlich aber es
kann auch mal ausfallen ja deswegen hat
man den Zweifel auch ein paar Kerzen und
ein paar Streichhölzer zu Hause und dann
ist natürlich wichtig dass man weiß wo
die sind falls es mal dunkel wird im
Dunkeln suchen ist auch schwierig wenn
man glauben
der Staat sei nur noch was was seinen
Bürgern alles mögliche liefern müssen
also so eine Art Supermarkt wo man
Schnäppchenjäger macht oder der Staat
muss jetzt nie von dem wollte ich muss
Angebote machen bessere Angebote und so
nein wenn ich ihn Umfragen
lese
dass viele Menschen lieber weniger
arbeiten würden
ich finde weniger aber nicht auch schön
aber auch nicht unser dringend das
Bedürfnis und ein erfülltes Leben nicht
ganz sicherlich eines indem man nur Spaß
hat man muss darauf setzen dass man nur
den hilft die es wirklich brauchen und
den anderen muss man sagen tut mir leid
ja ich verstehe gut dass du nicht mehr
dafür bezahlen möchtest
aber zur Not kannst du jetzt mal eine
Urlaubsreise nicht machen
oder vielleicht musste zur Not hier in
Deutschland irgendwo Urlaub machen und
kannst nicht auf die
Galapagos Inseln oder was der Kuku hin
ich möchte noch eine Frage stellen die
ich vor zwei Wochen im Friedrich Merz
gestellt habe habe ich gefragt ob wir in
diesen Krisenzeiten wo wir nicht nur
corona-krise haben sondern jetzt eben
vor allen Dingen Tiefe Energiekrise und
man in solchen Zeiten wo man den
Menschen so viel zumutet beispielsweise
eine restriktive Flüchtlingspolitik
braucht weil sich Menschen schneller
überfordert fühlen ich war immer dafür
dass wir eine Migrationspolitik
betreiben wo mir den Ärmsten der Armen
im Rahmen unserer Möglichkeiten so gut
wie möglich helfen
aber nicht indem sie alle nach Europa
kommen aber Sie müssen menschenwürdig
behandelt werden denn das ist nun ein
Prinzip Europas gewesen aber wenn wir
sagen jetzt
haben wir es nicht mehr so gut jetzt
können wir auch nichts geben schauen Sie
ich kann mich an die Jahre
die ersten Jahre nach dem Krieg schon
insofern erinnern Flüchtlinge waren auch
bei uns
damals nicht angesehen im in der
Kleinstadt im Schwarzwald wo ich gelebt
habe aber Flüchtlinge waren ja nicht
irgendwelche Menschen aus Pferden
Kontinenten sondern das waren Menschen
aus östlichen Teilen Deutschlands
gewesen oder die eben irgendwo ihre
Heimat verloren hatten und den hat man
natürlich nicht gerne vielleicht
manchmal aber man hatte ihn geholfen und
darin zeigt sich ja die Menschlichkeit
einer Gesellschaft dass sie egal wie es
Ihnen geht wie schlecht du das Gute ihn
geht dem dem schlechter geht helfen wenn
sie können also hat Friedrich Merz schon
einen Punkt ohne dieses Wort
sozialtourismus wenn er von diesen
pull-faktoren spricht dass wir schon
gucken müssen wie groß die Anreize sind
die wir setzen Herr Friedrich Merz hat
darauf hingewiesen und er hatte ja da
hat er ja völlig recht das Problem der
Migration auf dieser Erde was ja durch
Krieg durch Hunger durch durch
ökologische Probleme dramatisch noch
verschärft werden wird
das ist nicht dadurch zu lösen dass alle
Menschen den schlecht geht nach Europa
kommen oder dahin wo es den Menschen
noch nicht schlecht geht und deswegen
muss man eine verantwortliche
Migrationspolitik betreiben die darf
aber nicht aber das hat ja auch nicht
gesagt kann unser Gegenteil aber so ist
es manchmal mit der Kommunikation wenn
du den falschen Begriff gebrauchst dann
kriegst du das nicht richtig wieder los
das ist nicht einfach aber gesagt hat er
ganz klar wir müssen eine
verantwortliche
Migrationspolitik betreiben gerade damit
wir den schwächsten auf dieser Welt im
Rahmen dessen was wir überhaupt leisten
können auch leisten
auch hilfeleisten gibt es in diesen
schweren Krisenzeiten wo man wenn man
über das Weltgeschehen nachdenkt
eigentlich nur deprimiert sein kann gibt
es Dinge über die Sie richtig lachen
können es gibt ein schönes evangelisches
Kirchenlied ergibt sich Strophe wir
machen unser Schmerz und Leid nur größer
durch die Traurigkeit der amerikanische
Botschafter der zurzeit der
Wiedervereinigung des Mauerfalls in Bonn
gewesen ist hat die Geschichte erzählt
er hat einen hohen amerikanischen
Offizier
1945 bei einer Fahrt durch eine der
zerstörten Städte in im Ruhrgebiet
begleitet
und dann stand in einer so einer Höhle
also so ein Fenster was nicht mehr war
in so einer Ruine eine Blechdose mit ein
paar Blumen drin und dann hat er
Offizier zu den Burner Walter seinem
Assistenten gesagt
schauen Sie sich das an dieses Volk wird
nicht untergehen wenn Menschen in einer
solchen Situation Blumen in eine
Blechdose ins Fenster stellen die werden
nicht untergehen und das darin steckt
die Wahrheit wir haben keinen Grund zu
resignieren
wir müssen tun was immer wir tun können
und wir wissen wissen dass es das wert
ist
und dann können wir uns darüber freuen
heute ist blauer Himmel die Sonne
scheint ja worüber wollen sie sich nicht
freuen
danke sehr Herr Schäuble für das
Gespräch
vielen Dank
[Musik]